皆さん週末ですよ
1週間頑張った自分によちよちして
ずっとこうがなんか
急いか頑張ってるっていう何かご褒美的なことを自分にした方がいいですよ
ずん大切にしてくださいハーゲンダッツああ
人生で初めて自分で買いました自分のために
管弦だっつの
オペラというスペシャルエディションです
ほい
凍ってる
僕らっぽいそうねっ
ほらぼくラップ一緒ということでハーゲンダッツ油ってことなんですけど
こんだけの量だの en 400字詰めんですよ
まずやばいそ詐欺でしょ
ハゲ立つ自分で買わないんですよ
お互いし
すっごいお金の無駄だと思うんですよね
うわぁ高そう
真っ黒この上にちょっとなんか金が乗っています金
や梅しそこれやこれやは一層
ぷーんこれやば1所
出せ普通こんなた大アイス食うだなぁ
あのスーパーカップ食べた方が絶対いいと思いません
けどヤバイっしょこれやばい
絶対うまいこれ
各期えっそう
やばいお
なんかすごいやばいこのだけの量で多分これは80円くらいあります
ライブを張った8本分の
あれですよ
ヤバイのは絶対バイ
様いただきます母
大
くわっを
普通のアイスです黒いっていうのは驚きでした一番
なんて言うあなたの
バニラでもないし
そこでもないしなんか
何とも言えないと思ってついていてますこれ
美味しいですよなんだ
アジアの関係なくてパンピーナッツっていう名前に何か価値があると思うんですよね
コンビニ限定らしいんだよ
ぜひね
ぜひねじゃあ
おまっ